and in doing so we identified a couple
key
elements firstly we were repeating the
same ggplot theme elements within a file
and across multiple different files
meaning we were copying code chunks
every single time we were creating a new
script and new plot um importantly this
wasn't standard across the board so if I
were creating a new plot I would open up
my script copy in this code chunk and
then make a small mod ification let's
say I wanted to increase the line weight
of my Axis or something like that um
that's not to say then that the next
person who goes and copies my code is
going to keep the same things and make
the same customizations so we were
having these repetitions but also lacked
uniformity across the
board secondly we were repeating hex
colors throughout our scripts and had as
Aaron mentioned multiple different
colors that were being used that we were
explicitly calling out with their hex
code hex codes each time and finally our
team had custom export parameters for
the size and DPI of our plots that we
were using for presentations um and
while we had this GG save function that
was ready to go at the end of each of
our scripts we still had to copy that
every time we were um creating a new
script and so doing this inventory
allowed us to then parse through our
code base and make decisions about what
we wanted to keep that we would then
pull into our standard plot uh plot
elements going forward so here you have
a mockup of our not and sketches
throughout this process and the
decisions that we made about formatting
and we took it a step further and
specifically ascribed for each plot
element um what we wanted those
decisions the the decisions to be and
the goal of this slide is not for you to
be able to to see every single element
on this um plot but to understand our
thought process behind what we were
doing we went through and specifically
said for the title this is going to be
an all capital letters 14-point font in
this very specific shade of dark gray
and we did this for every element of the
plot from the caption to The annotation
to grid lines and even to the source
note at the bottom of the
plot this effort to better document and
understand our previous work allowed us
to then move into GG plot seamlessly
with this mockup and start building our
custom refinements on top of what
already existed in
ggplot we focused on three main buckets
to um make these refinements to our
custom plot branding starting with the
plot elements themselves we were really
motivated to adhere to data
visualization principles namely to
declutter our plots and show the data to
do so we really liked theme minimal from
ggplot as a great starting point for
this and leverag the replace function
from ggplot to then make small
refinements on top of theme minimal
based on our notes from all of our
previous code and so this was making
adjustments to things from title and
subtitle all the way down to things like
ticks and
margins for typ face this was one of the
ways that we could really distinctively
make this style our own our agency has a
branding guide and while this branding
guide doesn't necessarily discuss too
much about data visualization principles
it does denote a specific web font to
use which was Source Dan Pro um and we
really wanted to use this font instead
of the three default fonts and ggplot
and to do so we used the extra font
package and gr devices which allowed us
to build in our custom um font Source an
Pro into our existing r package and so
by packaging all of these elements into
their own central theme and building in
a custom font for our package we were
able to pull all of these elements
together into one simple function called
SI style and the idea behind SI style is
that any user could pick this up and
pipe this into their existing GG plot
code and then immediately be able to
standardize their um their plot elements
to our style so visual hierarchy axes
white space the likes while still
remaining flexible and customizable to
the user so the last leg of the the
stool is color right we needed to create
something that really made it our own so
as krishma mentioned we have this
branding guy that doesn't talk about
visualization for our agency but we
wanted to use some of the colors right
there's some nice colors going on here
there's just not a big enough pallette
to make it useful for data visualization
nor is there enough contrast to really
make this accessible so those were our
two priorities so we Ed this as a
starting place to work from and we pick
two of the USA uh branded colors and
from there we used free uh software uh
Adobe color palatable and viz palette to
to play with the Hue and saturation of
those two colors to then adjust them do
additional adjustments and then make
sure that there was enough contrast
going on and as a result we came up with
our own colors that were similar yet
distinct from the original and had
enough contrast in them and then from
there we built out our own a larger set
of colors uh and a gray and then each of
those then had lights that we could use
and then we defined additional colors
for each of our plot elements that we
could use to standardize them if you're
feeling a little overwhelmed by having
to make all these decisions about color
we really really really love uh Lisa
Charlotte MTH she has some unbelievable
resources that we relied on in talking
about color for data visualization and
how to put together uh color for a style
guide and she's working on a book right
now uh that I I think is coming out
later this year so with those three
pillars in place uh we were able to
create a package right we started small
we had our SI style that krishma
mentioned earlier uh and we're able to
have a good starting place for something
everybody could use and to make it so
that everybody could use this boom we
pushed it up to GitHub and it would
became accessible not just to our team
but to our colleagues in the missions
and uh our other uh agencies that we're
working with so we start started like I
said with SI style uh got the job done
and then we expanded from there that SI
style has about nine different uh
alterations that you can use just to be
flexible and then we as we realized
there were more things that we were
repeating we built out additional
functionality to interpolate colors and
to make sure that our exports were the
same every single time regardless of
whether krishma was doing it or I
was so I think everybody right is
familiar with Bas ug plot and those
colors right you would not be you know
if you've ever used it looks pretty
standard and so it gets the job done but
to those points that Laura was talking
about earlier we added our own style
here to help at a baseline provide some
uh differences to help with focus on
other things so we have scale fill SI
that we've just added on top of ggplot
which is providing the Colors by default
from our color palette which then the
user could adjust to different colors on
our palet and then lastly this SI style
grid um which is providing a y grid
instead of just a standard SI style and
then you're seeing changes in our title
our caption uh the strip text the top
looks different the placement of uh the
legend so all these are conscious
decisions that we're doing to make
declutter our our graphs and make them
more
legible so the great thing about this is
it just works right we don't have to
think about these things everying single
time you just add a line or two to your
Cod your ggplot code and it just
works the last piece of the puzzle for
us was to take all of this work that we
had built in the r environment and
package it into a tool agnostic style
guide so we had a tool that worked
really really well and powerfully in R
to standardize our plot elements and
apply visual coherence to our visuals
but the next step was to think about how
we could socialize this more broadly
within our team and make this something
that was useful to folks regardless of
of their data visualization platform of
choice we also recognized that the
glitter package alone was not enough
let's take this visual for instance this
is a pepar plot that's built in Excel
and it's trying to convey the point of
funding being transitioned to local
Partners in the blue and while we can
leverage the glitter package to apply
our standard plot elements to um add
some visual coherence with our font
colors and white space there's still
something missing from this visual to
really effectively tell the story and
that missing piece is the intentional
use of data visualization principles
throughout your plot things like sorting
your data to more effectively show your
point or encoding the key takeaway
message into the title to make it
meaningful or strategically leveraging
labels to add context to your plot all
things that can't be built into a into
an r package and this really solidified
for us the need to have one resource
that anyone can come to that explains
why we made the choices we made for our
custom plot elements but also outlin the
data visualization principles that you
need to um to be thinking about when
making plots on your
own we wanted this to be like a paint by
Numbers if you will where no matter
where you are in your data visualization
Journey you have tools and resources
that you can easily build upon and have
guidepost for what you're doing and why
and so our data visualization style
guide was born and this style guide
takes you through all of the elements
that you should be thinking about when
creating a data visualization of your
own it also details out the choices that
our team made when creating our custom
um themes and colors and acts as one
Central resource for our entire office
of 300 people to come to as their um
data visualization
Hub so what where do we go from here
well before glitter and the style guide
um our teams were working in silos and
often were creating produ products that
lacked visual coherence and ended up
creating a lot of cognitive load um
anytime you were looking at your your
presentations and while this um before
and after is zoomed out you can still
see a little bit more visual coherence
in the slide deck on the bottom in
addition to this just looking nice and
professional our team has seen numerous
benefits since the introduction of these
tools firstly um our team has seen
significant efficiency gain efficiency
gains since the introduction of the
style guide and the art package instead
now of all of our um colleagues having
to reinvent the wheel every single time
they have a foundation that they can
build off of and can spend more time
focusing on the analytic questions at
hand this style guide has also enabled
us to create unified branding within our
team and recognition of products that
are coming out of our office and as um
mentioned in the previous talk having
visualizations that look nice matters
and it also improves your data
storytelling um and the quality of your
analytic products from a visibility
standpoint um our team has been able to
share what we've learned throughout this
process with other teams in the Federal
space who are looking to implement
similar processes within their
organizations and finally having these
Central data visualization resources
makes for easier onboarding of new staff
uh we can speak firsthand that these
resources do not stand alone within our
team it's created a community of
collaboration within our office and also
lowers the barriers to entry for folks
who are looking to get engaged in data
visualization or even in the r
space um so all in all these processes
take time and they take effort but in
doing so you're not only enabling
yourself to succeed but others in your
team to succeed well into the future our
framework was to First do an inventory
of um our universe of outputs and
workflows and find pieces that we could
build upon and then move those into
ggplot to make refinements to our plot
elements type face and any decisions to
be made about color and then finally
take all of that work and package it
into a tool agnostic style guide that
you can share more broadly within your
teams and create um and generate more
buyin and and promote accessibility
we've shared this framework with you
today in the hopes that this will be
useful and beneficial to you and your
teams so that next time you don't need
to start from a blank canvas rather um
you don't instead of starting from
scratch you have a pallette that you can
work off of you have tools that can help
you get there and guid post for what
you're doing and why thank you all for
coming today and we hope that this talk
has inspired you to add a touch of
litter to your data visualization
workflows
thank you thank you both for a great
talk and we have time for a couple of
questions uh one question is have you
thought about Glitter for plotly so I
guess people are interested in you know
interactive sure I mean we haven't but I
mean it's kind of a next extension that
we have all this built out that wouldn't
be
hard okay second question how can none I
guess you partially answer this already
but how can none our user use your
resources yeah I think the style guide
is really that bridge to allow folks to
to to engage in the r space with this
but also pull this into their other
visualization tools so our team also
works across Tableau and Excel and we've
been able to pull these guiding
principles into our work in those um
software as
well um how do you convince others at
your organization to use your
package we don't
so we we within our office have uh been
able to basically
showcase what this can do uh but we are
in a federal uh space where there are
these branding and guidelines and so
most of our work is internal and so
we're able to kind of skirt around that
for now uh by just doing this
internally lastly what was the trickiest
part about the process to set up your
design in terms of selling it to the
office as well as making decisions
it's tough I mean I think just the time
like communication that it has to take
you have to be able to show your product
and the difference that it's going to
make and then also get some Buy in from
the people you're working with to make
those changes from doing what they're
doing to kind of buy into the rest of
this thank you very much thank
[Applause]
you